tra gli agenti ragazzi e vedo che sono
video questa è la seconda parte di
ghiaccio in glorie vi lasciamo il video
quale voleva male e tanta buona c'è
qualcuno è riuscito a fare sta partito
giocatore forte ma sicuro ma non è così
finito che siamo scemi un tasto per
sganciare il bambino perché guarda
abbiamo ottenuto reggina con la gira con
la gira frater farà passare per ora no
no no ma ti taglio la gola un mezzo
tratteggiate levati tematiche ginocchio
piegato proprio per schivare il chip
ponte allucinante sta cosa
si no le rughe sino a me sembra solo dai
tranquilli che viene sempre lei che sei
venuto sia per tua madre [ __ ]
sono carico stato un cazzo fai lo slalom
è un buon mondiale lanciatore start
again immagini di 100 per 100 brumotti
ma io ci sono morto perché tu ci vai
sopra e tu dove sei andato a [ __ ] mai
troppo lento ma bastava andare lincoln
importante che noi e noi un'ora che ci
proviamo e dai e frate alle lane e la
[ __ ] tutta la me e dài e dài e dài ma
non ci voglio credere
qualcuno dopo una merda ma non ho che
cazzo fai non finisce se arriverà una
camicia con me qua a si era già allora
giù così uno ad uno bravo la cosa che
salta salta bravissimo qui dove tutti un
ottimo ci vogliono bene sta facendo
tutto il finale fino al finale trasmette
il mio numero d'iscrizione 50 [ __ ] mi
chiamo grazie se facevi questo ti cambia
la sede renderà fine anno in piedi
ragazzi persona pura destra diventare
avete contattare surreal power per la
[ __ ]
lui è disponibile lo stesso anch'io
capisci che non lo capisco lo so non lo
so non si capisce nulla riguardo sta già
dando a quell'ora latta meriti conti
continuare perché ai premi grazie questo
noi lo aspettavo proprio la palla non
appena memorie genera destra destra
destra mikado e tutto il corso abbiano
mai fatta oddio cos'è 6 gesù cristo
no 6th frati center
[Musica]
t come fai a prato di fuori non puoi
entrare aspetta non ci deve essere
qualche modo per entrare strano ma
difende la parabolica
la cosa la parabolica la parabolica
tonioni di ogni occhio senza lo
scrittore e ora nei fondarsi sotto nel
vostro guardaroba di lancio il gusto di
sotto nel vuoto stavolta nel vuoto
backflip balla fa kart da tempo limite e
fatela rosolare che sono i trial grosso
rosso lo so anch'io avrei detto rosso se
era giusto grande piano ci sono arrivato
alla fine ci alla fine traguardo
traguardo ammessi finisce giro e vinci
ti spara nella stratosfera e vinci può
essere sì mi fa morire per forza perché
la fine moneta penserà mila e sto
tremando per gli sta contenendo cosa
ok forse una gamba persona camera e
ancora che amazon lo sa ma lasciano
quasi porca [ __ ] dai a voi l'onore
neanche mi rimbalzo cadavere primati
povincia di rimbalzo cadavere sì sì sì
no no sono se morì dopo che un albero
sganciato nella stratosfera kick ass
guardatele cibo che i muscoli ben
immaginare da vera questa velocità con
la bicicletta di drogati sì o no o
rimbalzo che la quale cadaveri quali
gradara liberi internare però se di
frenate fra possiamo solo vincere
infrenare tu sei partito che a torto usa
la barra spaziatrice per chi usa il
freno a mano che non c'è stata da vinci
39 però in arrivo raga il figlio vivo
usarci una mano fra te ne rallenta mamma
penare impennare impennare infezioni
vaginali
in arrivo del mare non è neanche
arrivato al mio a testa del bambino si
questo calore posizionato per il nuovo
trailer di saw l'enigmista minorenni
passa il bambino altrimenti no
però frenano sento nel nero questo
quando lei ho frenato prima indietro
tutto vedi rimane un pezzo di non ci
voglio credere
regione di merda non ci voglio credere
nola beh dai ragazzi dai porca [ __ ]
il livello più di una cosa fare a
madonna via bambino qui lo sapeva ha
calcolato stupidi front flip tutto così
ferma appena create adesso io credo
adesso più o meno cioè adesso bravo
esatto bravo
bye bye bye bye attenzione su rea
potrebbe concludere questo vitous uri al
power sorry sorry sorry frigobar
sorellina per suri a big a tutte le
ragazze [ __ ] del foto delle tette dai
vent'anni è che stanno ora questa geremi
odia maggiorenni il suo real power
maggiorate sia maggiorenne solihull
paura indagati sono facciamo l'ultimo
l'ultima volta
berna cazzo è sta roba questo stiamo
perso ma c'è chi l'incivile persona pura
curiosità 1 tutto dietro è vero il conto
di hvb ora oggi oggi occhio occhio poi
quindi questa mattina adesso deve
iniziare buti rivolta lasciare
dico perché ti spara le palle pezzi di
merda ok questo è andato anche il nostro
motto è bellissimo ha svelato ma non so
nella lama perché è morto viene ancora
vivo città mi serve solo un tentativo
cit e guarda già nostra citt by caverna
di vedere che sentimento loro pino lo
vedo neanche la è che la vista e la
prima volta che voi saprete grazie a me
quindi se mai mi sono fatto male giorni
quando rottura bravissime ci sono altre
nove però ragazzi che cazzo sul rischio
importato da noi non vedo nulla c'è una
palla c'è una palla strano almeno la
terza delle misure in direct
ma che cosa vai di sopra sovrana ma ci
sono l'avevo bravo paura delle lame
frate ok ma tipici artificiali vitalità
destra non ci sarà invece a ricciardi
miceli miss arrivi ci arrivi vai vai e
questo è andato ok ora devo solo occhio
che disumane prendere per ricevere una
pubblica nella schiena vado d onore 20
metri che guarda anche culo ma è ok e
ora sinistra a destra destra che
riguardano il corno su questo sconcio
lei che pure ho fatto lì non ci vogliono
grafico già dato che generico arata
ha ragione orca vacca non è per questo
quando rocco siffredi prova sverginare
l'unico modo per fare questo livello è
uno solo devi pregare gesù cristo è
andare a brescia ma tanto non canta non
c'è un modo caso minuscolo sogno del
nostro piano allora era solo per
allenamento adesso li facciamo bene ora
di reagire e cercare colpe
addio c'è la cassa di frutta sul retro
no agli atti ho preso degli archi in
faccia attendere lo speed ok
volevo passare qua o persona di saldo
per
ok no io sono felice qui e salvo basta
perfetto ma e non riesco a salire don
franchini in dirittura so devo fare così
capito da voi senza una ruota ma dove
cazzo sbattuto non c'era niente da fare
ce ne è già visibile perché i muri
invisibili sono da sempre visibile per
forza dati delle scienze occhio
occhio anche bravo peraltro non c'è non
ci stima c'è un buco non ci sono gli
spazi c'è ma non c'è una fisica è fatta
un po a caso di preparazione per suri
non va bene
mariano segala all'una e mezza poi fai a
urlare il recente un'attrice niente
possono fare sempre pronto
si stanno stupendo perché noi vogliamo e
sono lui e dell'una e mezza a casa mia
ma a casa mia poi urlare perché la gente
è abituata a peggio cioè ai video porno
andiamo avanti da molto bravo forza su
un impianto che cosa stai guidando
quindi per le maree da ieri liscio e
alessia si ubriaca
porca [ __ ] e vai col liscio anche
stavolta è bravissimo ma dai ma qui si
frena con lo spazio lo spazio con dietro
dolcemente i tool di chi mente avanti
così pensai di calcolo di di serie di
buoni 90 bellissimo a queste era
palesemente cantù di sotto
su questo toro stai scherzando nazione
ma come dentista di salvando meriti
molto meriti l'aquila mister chirurgica
non a caso potentino
il signor mercato c'è poi vincerà il
giallo cos'è ed edito dite di fare
dietrofront di qualche prossima stato
anche riuscito a prendo quello che poi
si vabbè dai vari martin garics meno 20
ce l'ha fatta e ora superare il 10
ma quella shame cazzo di fare il tunnel
e adesso devo fare invece sono centrali
sono loro di tipo oh scusa non c'è il
cerchio intorno si è critico ma non lo
vedo io dico non c'è non si vede ma
saremo il parcheggio di linate è vero
immaginando da solo tra l'altro ok
eccolo alle lame varie caste lo dico
solo io so tutto valorosi dubai 2000 da
solo che ho creato poco in fieri ha
chiesto cassini e allora occhio
gravissimo fra siamo alla fine style è
premio sordi e favorire cazzo avresti
finto due livelli e saresti stato il
solo perché se mio fratello 9
direttamente
no non ero morto ma lei diretto poi così
no vuol dire no no lorena zitto ios ho
capito io so ci prendi il jump i tuoi
freni easy peasy ma non puoi frenare se
sei qua sì ma io ho frenato
io ho sempre l'idea di andare diretto da
dato che lo aspetta aspetta tg rai su te
stesso roteare in modo che il furgone
catania ipotenusa to man of africa come
carta se avevamo fatto noi si è spaccato
la gamba ma come cazzo sei fatto ai
ragazzi io ringrazio sul reattore per
aver finito livelli perché sono non
avremmo vinto ma che cazzo ne va bè
ragazzi sparavigna vi sia piaciuto
ringrazio stefani sugli appalti krhin
descrizione io vi ringrazio ha visto
questo video cosa mi piace anche vari
social committee dotata la descrizione
che si scateni ci dividiamo il prossimo
video per ragazzi ma chi l'ha visto e
l'ho sentito e basta ma c'è un pezzo di
pizza sulla mia 7 mar